según el nivel de actividad el corazón
late aproximadamente entre 60 y 100
veces por minuto
puede ser mayor durante la actividad
física o menor en descanso un ritmo y
una frecuencia cardíacos normales
garantizan que la sangre oxigenada con
alto contenido de oxígeno llegue a todos
los órganos del cuerpo como el cerebro y
los pulmones
un grupo de células en el corazón
denominado sistema de conducción
cardíaca utiliza impulsos eléctricos
para controlar la velocidad y el ritmo
de cada latido
cada latido comienza en la aurícula
derecha en el nodo sino auricular o s a
luego se propaga a través de las paredes
de las cavidades del corazón
denominadas aurículas y ventrículos y
hacen que se contraigan este proceso se
repite con cada latido
los problemas en el sistema de
conducción cardíaca hacen que el corazón
tenga un ritmo normal denominado
arritmia esto puede producir un pulso
irregular
las arritmias pueden ocurrir en las
aurículas o en los ventrículos
los tipos de arritmias son
fibrilación que es un ritmo cardíaco
irregular
taquicardia que es un latido rápido con
más de 100 latidos por minuto
y bradicardia que es un latido lento de
menos de 60 latidos por minuto
la fibrilación auricular es el tipo más
frecuente de arritmia los impulsos
aleatorios provocan la fibrilación de la
aurícula o que ésta se contraiga rápida
y aleatoriamente
la taquicardia en la aurícula se
denomina taquicardia supraventricular
en la taquicardia auricular focal las
pequeñas áreas dentro de la pared
auricular inicia no pasan impulsos que
hacen que la aurícula se contraiga
rápidamente pero con un ritmo regular
en el aleteo auricular las áreas más
grandes dentro de la pared auricular
inicia no pasan impulsos que hacen que
la aurícula se contraiga rápidamente
pero con un ritmo regular
la taquicardia también puede ocurrir en
los ventrículos con contracciones
rápidas y regulares el cuerpo no recibe
suficiente sangre porque los ventrículos
se contraen antes de que se llenen
completamente con sangre
el tipo de arritmia más grave es la
fibrilación ventricular en la que muchos
impulsos aleatorios se disparan
rápidamente dentro de las paredes
ventriculares durante la fibrilación
ventricular los ventrículos tiemblan en
lugar de latir esto constituye una
emergencia médica porque el corazón no
puede bombear sangre eficazmente al
cuerpo ni a sí mismo
a veces los problemas en el nodo s/a o
en la trayectoria de los impulsos
eléctricos hacia los ventrículos pueden
ser la causa de los latidos lentos en la
bradicardia
si el corazón late demasiado lento el
cuerpo no recibe suficiente sangre
oxigenada
según el tipo de arritmia un médico
puede recomendar uno o más de los
tratamientos a continuación
cambios en el estilo de vida como una
dieta saludable para el corazón
y realizar actividad física
y dejar de fumar
medicamentos como medicamentos
antiarrítmicos o beta bloqueadores
ablación con catéter un procedimiento
mediante el cual se colocan alambres
finos en el corazón para que destruyan
el tejido que causa la arritmia con
energía fría o caliente
y dispositivos implantables como un
marcapasos o un desfibrilador
cardioversor para corregir la velocidad
o el ritmo del corazón